Voiceover: What I want to do in this video
is talk a little bit about
money and interest rates
and do it in kind of a
microeconomic framework,
so that we understand the relationship
between the supply of
money and demand for money
and the price of money, which we'll see
is what interest rates actually are.
Once we do that, then we'll
be able to be more fluent
in discussing money and
interest rates and supply
and demand and price of money
in a macroeconomic context.
Maybe the most confusing thing,
when you view money in
a microeconomic context
is what is the price of money?
You might already be
guessing the price of money
is the interest rate.
To understand that a little
bit better, the best way
to think about it is you're
not necessarily buying money.
Interest is rent on money.
If I said, "What is the
price of an apartment
"in my neighborhood?"
Someone might say a one-bedroom apartment,
and that actually is
pretty close to the prices
where I live, here in northern California.
If you want even the most basic,
one-bedroom apartment,
it's going to run you
about $1200 per month,
which is about $14,400 per year.
We should say per apartment per year.
This is essentially the
cost of your apartment.
Now, if I went to the bank and I said,
"Hey, I want to borrow $10,000."
Maybe I want to buy a car or something,
they would quote an interest rate.
They would say, "Okay, you can borrow that
"at an interest rate of -
I don't know.
Interest rates are pretty low right now.
They'll say, "You can borrow
that at an interest rate
"at 5%."
To see that is essentially
the cost of renting money,
we could essentially
just say that this is 5 -
We could view this as
$0.05 per dollar per year.
Once again, when you're
renting an apartment,
it was $14,000 per apartment per year.
Now, at an interest rate of 5%,
that is $0.05 per dollar per year.
It's the exact same thing.
This right over here is the rental price
on the actual money that I'm borrowing.
Once you have that in your head
and you feel comfortable with that,
now we can actually draw
a supply and demand graph
and the microeconomics context.
Now that we know how to
think about the price
of money.
Let's draw a little
supply and demand diagram
right over here and we're
going to, like we often do
in our little economic models we do,
we're going to super oversimplify it.
We're going to not think
about things like credit risk
and the chances of probability
that people do pay back
or won't pay back the
money and things like
(unintelligible) and all of that.
We'll just assume that
everyone is going to pay back
the money and they're all risk free.
They're all going to do
exactly what they said.
In this axis right over here, this is -
Let's call this the
market for borrowing money
for 1 year.
As we'll see and you might already know,
they'll have different
prices for borrowing money
for different lengths of time.
I might charge you more
to borrow money for a year
than I would charge
you for borrowing money
for a month, because
maybe I won't have access
to that money or there's a bigger risk
that something might happen in that year,
so I'll charge you more for it.
I have to fix the year.
The market for borrowing money for 1 year.
Most of these supply and demand graphs,
the vertical axis, we have price, but now,
as we just indicated, the price of money
is really just the interest rate.
I'll call this price, so this is our -
Same yellow, so this is our price axis
and it's measured as
interest rate percentage.
Interest rate is how
we're going to measure it.
This right over here, let's
say that that is 30% interest,
this is 15% interest, and
then this would be 10%, 5%,
this would be 20%, 25%.
Pretty good.
Then over here we would
have the quantity of money
and I'll just pick some values here.
We could even say that that
is in billions of dollars.
We could size it right, based
on whether we're talking
about our town, our city, or
whatever, the whole world,
or whatever it is.
It depends on what
currency and all of that,
but we're just assuming
that we're on some island
with one currency and all the rest.
Let's say that this is 1
billion, 2 billion, 3 billion,
4 billion, and 5 billion.
You can imagine, let's first think
about the demand curve.
We could think of it as
a marginal benefit curve.
Those first few dollars
that are out to be lent,
there are someone who is going to get
a huge marginal benefit of it.
They want to take that,
either they want to borrow it
and use it for some type of consumption
that they want to buy
that would make them very,
very, very happy, or at least
they think it'll make them
very happy, or they want
to use it for some type
of investment, where they're like,
"Wow, if I could just borrow some money,
"I have this no-risk
investment that's just going
"to make me a gazillionaire."
Those first few dollars
there's huge demand,
huge marginal benefit for you.
You could use as a willingness to pay
for those first few dollars is very high,
so maybe it is way up here.
People are willing to pay an excess of 30%
for those first few dollars.
Then, as there's more and more dollars,
the incremental next borrower
gets a little bit less
marginal benefit from it.
You would have a declining demand curve
that looks something like this.
This is the exact same thought process
as you would have if we were
thinking about the market
for ice cream of if we're
for apartments or for anything else.
This is our demand curve.
When we think about the supply curve,
same exact thought process
as we would for supply
of any product.
Those first few dollars, the
people lending the money,
there are probably people
there willing to lend
for very little.
They have nothing else
to do with that money.
Another way to think of it is
they have very little to do
with that money.
Their marginal cost of lending that money
is very low.
The supply curve might start over here.
People will start to be
willing to lend the money
to very low interest rate.
This looks like about 1%.
Then, each incremental
dollar, the opportunity cost
for that lender is going
to get higher and higher.
The interest for that
next incremental dollar
is going to get higher and higher.
We've now drawn the
supply and demand graphs
for the market for
borrowing money for 1 year.
This is right here.
This is the supply and this is in billions
of dollars per year.
This is how much is going
to be lent in that year
and it's for borrowing money for a year.
As we see, we can view
money just like we can view
any other product.
There's going to be an
equilibrium price here,
an equilibrium quantity.
The way I drew it right over
here, the equilibrium price
and remember the price
of money is really just
the interest rate.
The equilibrium price
right over here is 10%,
which you could view as
$0.10 per dollar per year.
The equilibrium quantity
of money that gets lent
and borrowed looks like it's about 2.7
or 2.8 billion dollars gets
lent and borrowed in that year,
in each year.
When we look at it this way,
then we can start thinking
about some macroeconomics phenomenon.
What happens if all of a
sudden everybody in the world
or in our little universe
right over here gets
a little bit more money
thrown in their pocket.
The government prints a bunch of money,
drops it from helicopters,
and everyone has more money
in their pockets.
Well, then, all of a sudden,
at any given interest rate,
the supply will go up.
The supply curve will
shift in this direction,
so we might have a new
supply curve that looks
something like this.
We might have a new
supply curve that looks
something like this.
Then, also, maybe the demand will go down.
At any given interest
rate, at any given price,
there will be less demand,
because those people
who needed to borrow money, now they have
to borrow less money.
This will shift to the left.
The new demand curve might look like that.
What happened?
What would be our new equilibrium price?
It depends how much I
shift one or the other,
but the way I drew it,
our equilibrium quantity
doesn't change much, but it could change,
depending on how much the
supply or demand shifts.
What does definitely
happen, when that money
got printed and distributed
to all of these people,
is now all of a sudden, the
equilibrium interest rate
has gone down.
The equilibrium interest rate now,
based on the way I drew
it, looks like it's closer
to about, I don't know, about 6%.
The whole -
You can even think of
another reality where,
all of a sudden, money
disappears from the market,
or a reality where, for whatever reason,
because of good marketing
or a psychological shift
in people, all of a sudden,
people want to save less,
so that there is less supply of money.
Or maybe, all of a sudden, there's all
these great investment opportunities,
so now there's more demand for money
and you could think about how these curves
would shift and what would
happen to the interest rate.
Just how you would think
about it for any good
or service in a microeconomic context.